but not all students are on board with
that message one high school are writing
a message to conservative commentator
ben shapiro today quote i am in favor of
walking to honor the victims but not in
favor of promoting gun reform I feel
like I have to choose between going
against my political values or looking
like a bad person I need help here now
ben shapiro editor-in-chief of daily
wire.com Ben good to see you tonight
you received several messages like that
right what did you tell them I mean I've
been getting legitimately dozens scores
of messages probably a hundred since
yesterday of students who are
disappointed at the way they feel
they've been bullied into joining the
school walk outs what I suggested is
walk out with your friends and hold up
signs that say things like standing with
children standing with the Second
Amendment or protect our lives arm
law-abiding people I mean the media has
put forward this message and they've
been doing this for years but it's
really I think accelerated in the last
few months and particularly in the last
few weeks then putting forward this
message that if you disagree with them
on gun control then this means you don't
care enough about the kids and now
they're activating these kids and
putting them out on the frontlines and
putting them in photo ops so that they
can essentially use them as political
human shields now listen the kids can
say whatever they want that's that's
their prerogative obviously but it is
the media that are choosing to elevate
these kids as moral authorities even
though tragedy and age don't confer any
sort of expertise on a given issue yeah
you know we spoke with a gun store owner
last night in Florida who refused to
sell a gun to the parkland shooter he
said I don't sell guns he was a former
Israeli military in the military in
Israel he said I don't sell guns to
people under 21
that's my practice that that's what I do
you know is there any room for some of
these measures that that some of these
kids would be in favor of well I mean I
think that you know it depends on the
measure and the question is what's the
level of public support see whenever
they take a poll and they say there are
tons and tons of people who are in favor
of gun control it's a really vague
statement it's like polls that show that
Americans are in favor of cutting the
size of government well that sounds
great until you get down to the brass
tacks of well what do you want to cut
when people say they're in favor of gun
control usually they think that means do
you think we should take measures that
would prevent mass shootings and the
answer of course is yes but that doesn't
necessarily boil down into law than
anybody like so there's still some
pretty significant controversy for
example over raising the age limit for
buying rifle
I mean if you can serve in the military
at 18 and you can vote at 18 then what
is the problem exactly with with buying
gun and at the same time and there is a
certain weird kind of argument that's
being made that kids who are 17 should
be making all of the public policy but
kids who are 17 are also not capable of
buying weapons so what exactly is the
age of adulthood now these are arguments
that we can have and I'm perfectly happy
to have them what I'm not happy to do
and what I think a lot of these students
were writing they are not happy about is
this this attitude that if you disagree
with people on politics that this means
that you can't even be part of the
conversation that the only people we
will talk to our people we agree with on
gun control measures that's actually a
form of nastiness it's a form of
political cuddling purvey in so many
schools and so many universities there's
only one way of thinking that's
acceptable in protest and that clearly
has been demonstrated today there's got
to be room for people to have disparate
voices in the country and exercise their
free speech and for people to respect
the argument on both sides